[Music]
hi everyone welcome to film independent
presents my name is matt warren i am the
senior manager of digital content here
at film independent and today we are
here to talk about one of my favorite
films of the year the voyeurs which is
now available to stream on amazon prime
video
you can see right in check out those two
what is he like a photographer
oh they're in love i don't think we
should spy on our neighbors
just because someone is allowing you to
look in on their lives doesn't mean it's
okay to watch
this might be a little problematic
i just wish we could hear what they were
saying
don't you ever feel guilty
it's like when you're so obsessed with
something
you forget to look around and go
what am i even doing
would it be strange if i asked to take
your picture
[Music]
and to do that we have that film's
incredible writer and director michael
mohan welcome michael so great to have
you thanks for having me matt appreciate
it
so i
to start with this conversation i want
to sort of talk about this era of erotic
thrillers that the voyeurs
is sort of
growing at the tradition of film that
that is sort of growing out of so uh to
begin if you could just talk about your
relationship to this
um sort of odd and occasionally
disreputable erotic thriller
genre and
you know how
how those films have sort of informed uh
your your path to this film yeah well i
kind of came to them a little late um i
had made this short film that played
festivals back in 2015 called pink
grapefruit where um sort of up to that
point i had been known for not known but
like i made a bunch of independent
projects that were
about that just sort of dealt with human
relationships and with that short i was
just trying to
inject a subtle level of suspense into
what was naturally happening
and and erotic i've used eroticism in in
in that film and in another short film
prior called xx
and
um after that experience with that short
film and seeing it with screen with
audiences and feeling
that sense of temperature you know rise
in the auditorium when they play
i uh
i wanted to figure out how to how to do
it on a bigger scale and paint with a on
a bigger canvas and
trying to figure out like what what do
audiences what do audiences want
what are they missing um and how can how
can sort of what i do naturally fit into
that conversation and it was around that
time that i saw fatal attraction for the
very first time
and films like that films like
unfaithful
um
you know adrian lines films body heat
wild things i mean there's so i mean
there's so many
and nobody's making them they sort of
stopped making them and they're so
i watched them all like they're so easy
to watch they're so easy like it's
tuesday night what are we gonna watch
yeah we'll watch you know unlawful entry
or you know a jagged edge or any any of
these movies they're so they're still so
fun um and the good ones are able to
sneak in these complex you know human
relationships and complex themes
and so i just sort of fell in love with
the genre i didn't understand why people
weren't making them and so this
the the aspiration to make this movie
was sort of born out of born out of that
and what's your theory as to why people
don't make these sorts of movies anymore
okay i'm curious i i've been asked this
question a lot and i
had i had an epiphany
i'm curious why do you think why do you
think they stopped
well i think
on the studio level it's
i imagine part of just the the
extraction of the sort of mid-tier
studio
uh program or
in general but uh a lot of that stuff
has
reinvented itself as streaming content
and television and episodic content but
not specifically this genre and
my guess might just be that people are
are afraid or
uh afraid of the material afraid of
you know the eroticisms you know so that
would be my guess
yeah i wondered because like the last
sort of proper if you if you discount
like the 50 shades of gray movies right
which i don't think are really thrillers
right
like the last the last true erotic
thriller i think was unfaithful in 2002
i think
and so i was thinking about this like
it's also a time when streaming internet
streaming internet video sort of came to
power and so i wonder if there's some
sort of connection
to like the fact that if you're gonna be
in one of these movies then suddenly
you know it can
it can be viewed online if that if that
might have have have sort of evolved
into how chaste how chaste movies sort
of have become yeah and that now we're
sort of used to this and we can ignore
it we can choose to ignore it and
therefore
we can create works that are a little
bit more daring um but i don't know this
is me completely theorizing because it
unfaithful made 120 million dollars
you'd think there'd be like a bunch of
copycats right after that movie came out
but there weren't
no it's it's it's it is unusual and
you know there's a great tradition of
and i say this like in the most
complimentary way but these like
perverted thrillers kind of going all
the way back to alfred hitchcock and
then
obviously uh brian de palma followed in
in those film sets
in the uh in those footsteps rather and
i i imagine
i imagine you drew from those two
filmmakers and body double and rear
window and perhaps you're even sick of
talking about at this point but i'd love
to talk about your
relationship to uh vertigo or uh rear
window rather and uh body double yeah
well it's interesting it's like you
can't make a movie like this without
watching all the what i call binoculars
like the binocular sub-genre you know
and rear window is definitely a
touchstone um and especially just
because in rear window like
people don't know this like rear window
has plot holes like there are things
about rear window that do not add up
like he moves a body in the middle of
the night and nobody sees it and so
anyways it's all of those things that
make you realize like oh if the audience
is on the ride if they're having a good
time with this movie
they're gonna go they're gonna
they're gonna see it through to the end
and just have a good time and the um
uh but body double i didn't actually see
until after i had finished the script
and
uh and then i watched and i was like oh
this has there's so many touch points
here um my favorite thing my favorite
thing about body double is the drill um
and how
the killer's drill is i i looked this up
because i was like this is so much like
slumber party massacre if you've ever
seen slumber party massacre i've seen it
now oh it's fantastic it's it's uh it's
directed by a woman it's it's really
like a it's a piece of like
it's serious feminist uh cinema um and
he did that as an homage to slumber
party massacre which i think is really
fun
um but uh but yeah i saw it afterwards
and
you know it's kind of it's kind of
strange but like i i
i have to be honest like i i have become
a diploma fan because of my film but i
wasn't the biggest diploma fan i wasn't
thinking about his movies going in um i
think the outside of adrian line's
movies from a writing perspective
because his directness i don't think he
quite has like a you don't see it it
like the visual style of indecent
proposal is so different from the visual
style of fatal attraction you know seems
like he's more of like someone who
responds to the the visual trends of the
time right right but
um i was going back to things like the
conversation right
um which is very grounded and down to
earth and the locations are really
really speak to who the characters are
but you get that sense of like someone
who's getting sucked down this rabbit
hole based on this tiny sliver of
information and so that sort of actually
a greater impact on me than yeah than
some of the things that would seem a
little bit more obvious
and when you're when you're working on a
screenplay for a story like this i'm
always curious
where
where the core idea is and then
you know how does it grow out do you
kind of start with
uh you know do you kind of start with
the reversals that you imagine happening
at the end of the film and find out a
way to back into them or do you kind of
start with this surface idea and then
figure out how to subvert it or invert
it or or how does that work
yeah yeah yeah so i think we should say
like right now if anybody is watching
this video and you haven't watched this
movie
stop
turn this off
go watch the movie we'll still be here
come back and then we'll answer this
question okay
go go watch it all right
so the people here have seen this movie
right okay
so i knew i knew from the outset the
instant i had this idea so i was i was
visiting a friend who lives in downtown
l.a i uh i i he had just moved into this
loft apartment i looked out his window
and i saw this couple across
across the street who were wandering
around their apartment like completely
naked right i looked to my friend i was
like hey do you know your neighbors like
they're right there and he's like oh are
they naked again
and and i was like oh is this did they
do this all the time he's like yeah they
did they do in fact i i bought the he
had bought binoculars from the um local
pawn shop he was like you want to take a
look and i was like
i wanted to but i also knew it was wrong
and so i knew there was something there
and i also knew there was something that
like
like that
like as i was sort of unpacking the idea
i was thinking about the idea of
instagram and the grass is always
greener and the fact that we're always
like sort of it's sort of like that was
a a literal version of this
um
[Music]
of this thing that we all we all do on a
day to day but like to make a movie
about instagram it's like who wants to
see that you know like like i the last
thing i want in my in movies is more
cell phones
but i figured i could tap into the
sentiment that we all feel when we
discover someone online and decide to
like pour through their history of you
know that we know may not even be it's
curated and we know it may not be real
or it may not be um
you know true a true indication of who
that it's never a true indication of who
that person is it's it's indication of
what that person wants us to think they
are
and and when i sort of clicked into that
i was like oh okay so the people across
the way they're putting on a this is a
show this if it's instagram this isn't
real
you know oh maybe they're watching maybe
they're watching
maybe there's a flip maybe the voyeurs
actually belong to maybe that's who
maybe maybe that the title applies to
the people across the way yeah and um
and so i had that i figured out the
twists first
and then everything else was was to
was to make that was to make that twist
uh satisfying even down to like the
construction who are the characters that
would be most apt to fall into this trap
um
and then and then you know the writing
process then became about like okay well
you know this is the movie not a limited
series and so
what what
what's the least amount of information i
need to provide in order to make in
order to make this uh once people are on
the ride what's the least amount of
information i need to provide in order
for people to make it to to have a fun
fun ride to the end
and it really does have that really
economical sort of clockwork thing that
i i love from
i i love from those uh diploma movies
and films like the conversation and
stuff
uh i i'd like to talk about sort of the
the use of
uh and we sort of touched on it in our
our discussion of why this genre of film
seems to have um evaporated this century
but the use of uh like nudity and
eroticism in the film and
and i want to talk about your approach
to sort of using that as a filmmaking
tool
and then uh how do you approach that
sort of sensitively both
both on what you're depicting and how
you're how you're staging it behind the
camera yeah totally well i'll i'll
answer your second part first um so so
in in terms of how to stage how to stage
these sex scenes or the scenes of
intimacy now i mean now that there are
intimacy coordinators it makes your job
so much easier
um but the work the work
involved in these scenes actually began
even before i cast the actors when i was
when i was approaching the cast i would
send them a little book like a
director's book that had sort of my
vision for the movie and where it came
from and why i wanted to make the movie
and there was a little section devoted
to it was a picture of of the band salt
and pepper and at the top it said let's
talk about sex and it was sort of how i
wanted to
you know i didn't want to just abide by
current intimacy coordinator guidelines
i wanted to set a new bar
and i wanted to talk about how i was
going to set that bar by by allowing the
actors to feel to to to have
um
agency and a voice in how their body is
portrayed
and
um and so they walked in knowing that
yes this was a movie with sex and if if
that made them uncomfortable they
shouldn't do they shouldn't do the movie
because the the scenes are in the script
but how i was going to film that was
going to be a collaborative process and
from there once they signed on i made a
second book that was just all about the
intimacy where i talked about each scene
in granular detail i had screenshots
from other movies that were that
represented angles that i was hoping to
get
um i talked like sort of very clinically
about like okay in this scene we might
see the side of your breast but we you
know like very very clinically right and
then i gave that to amanda blumenthal
our intimacy coordinator and i said
no pressure this is the vision this is
my vision for it but this is this is an
early vision of it you know it's not
this isn't
this is malleable because these are the
actors that we cast and i want them to
be
i want them to have a voice and be
protected and so she was able to have a
conversation with the actors that was
really because you read a sex scene in a
script and oftentimes it's just like a
handful of sentences and so you don't
know
what the director has in mind and here
it was like almost like clinical detail
and so she's able to have that
conversation with the actor where i'm
not present
and therefore any even though i'm i'd
like to think that i'm a pretty
approachable and easy guy to talk to
like
it completely removes the any power
dynamic between an actor and a director
because actors want to make directors
happy and here they have a chance to be
like oh i don't want to do this or or
hey i actually want to go further in
some cases they're like i want to go
further here you know um i really want
to
i think that this scene should should be
x y and z
and then amanda is able to take that
back to me we have a meeting about it
and
and it's all
it's all sort of expectations have been
said i can then talk to the
cinematographer discreetly about sort of
what the challenges may or may not be
and then we sort of figure out the
blocking to satisfy the actors and
and obviously
it it could change from there too like
there are there are times where you know
if an actor were to show you know even
though there's like a nudity like
there's like a writer that they sign
yeah but if they show up on set and they
don't want to do it that day when no
one's going to make them do it well we
always had like a plan of attack if if
someone became uncomfortable or if
someone just that day
felt bloated you know what i mean like
you figure it out and you just be cool
people to work with just be good human
beings and it's pretty
it's pretty easy and so um the intimacy
coordinator made all of that possible
and then you know on the day she's there
to um to make sure that all the
expectations are are matched she closes
the stats she she helps with breath
mints and things like that right um
uh but in terms of the approach you had
also asked about the approach to nudity
yeah
and so i think you know i don't want to
be an apologist for this because i think
that films
should it's just i think part of it's
just like
cinema has been so chased it seems so
bizarrely out of the ordinary to see a
movie with nudity
and we constantly go like i watched a
movie this i watched a movie this
weekend where a person got stabbed
and the knife went through their chin
and out their nose
and it was like a mainstream movie that
just came out and no one's up in arms
about that but the instant you show a
pair of boobs it's like oh my god whoa
what is this filmmaker doing um and so i
don't want to be an apologist for that
um but
i do think in this film the film's about
voyeurism it's called the voyeurs it's
about looking at something
you're not you don't feel like you
should be seeing or being being turned
on by something and then wondering if
you should be honoring those those those
biological desires um
both with the characters and with the
audience and so i felt justified in
doing it um i felt justified that this
is
this is the best way to articulate that
theme
um and i tried to i tried to be tactful
in terms of
how the nudity was sort of deployed i
mean it's in some instances you know
when you're shooting a
shot through binoculars you know
everything was we we stay in the pov of
pippa and thomas the whole time right
i'm never getting coverage across the
way that i couldn't get
and so when you're in a shot that can't
be any tighter than waist up
you know if if you're a woman and you
take off your clothes there's no way to
frame that shot otherwise you know
um so it's sort of just practically
speaking there was there was that
constraint but then
you know again it's just part of the
allure i think um that that fits into
the theme
yeah i i don't think a film like this
works without you know you can't do you
can't go halfway with uh with the film
like this and have it
hit the way that you want it to yeah i
mean i think that the performance i mean
but truly if any of the actors did show
up and didn't want to do it we had a
plan it just wouldn't be as i just don't
think the film would be as visceral but
i would still be very happy to make that
you know i
you can't
it's such a like with this sort of thing
it's such a collaboration that no matter
you can't go into it with this grand
vision
of like well it has to be this way
because
you would be a really awful human being
if if if you weren't able to be
malleable with that vision so
you know
yeah i think i just got lucky and that
the actors were very brave and very bold
and wanted and wanted to do wanted to to
achieve this vision of the movie and i
think it's
i think the the sec the primary sex
scene in this film is it is it is the
scene i am most proud of in anything
that i've ever done
well i i wanted to maybe step outside
the sex scenes and talk
more about this uh
your collaboration with the the actors
in general and particularly with uh
sydney who is terrific in the film and
thank you yeah it really wouldn't work
without it and i know that you guys
could work together on everything sucks
and uh maybe talk through the process of
uh putting her into this role and
how he developed this uh character with
her yeah well it's interesting i think
this character so so yeah i worked with
sydney years ago and it was she's
incredible like we had only scratched
the surface of what she was capable of
and
and
you know and she's also just very down
to earth and very
like she's a bookworm she reads all the
time
she was kind of the den mother to like
she was a little bit older than the
other actors and so she like took them
under her wing and would organize trips
with them and things it was she's just
like a really really
really top-notch human being
and um and so i knew that
uh
when i was making this film like this
this character
she makes a lot of decisions that the
audience may not agree with and so i
needed someone really down to earth in
order to be able for audiences to
um want to go down those rabbit holes
with her right and so
um so it was a no-brainer you know i was
you know as a as a fan it made all the
sense in the world as a friend i was
obviously nervous to ask her because the
intimacy but you know um we you know
with all the it was it turned out to not
be an issue at all
um and when we were working on her
character it was
for me it was like just trying to tap
into the side of sydney that
i knew that i personally knew
um
that's not to say that there aren't
differences between sydney sweeney and
pippa there are
but
but there's like this goofy
goofy enthusiastic
bookworm
side to sydney that i just knew
if i could just get her to lean into
that side of herself
it was it was innate it was not going to
take much work you know
um
and so
and i think that her and i our rapport
is you know take myself
the work is very hard and so i try not
to take myself too seriously i try to
like make sure the actors never feel
like like i think the worst way to
direct is if you if the actors feel like
they're like getting it right or getting
it wrong i think the process of of
i i love i love it when an actor tries
something
and
and without any regards to whatever the
outcome goal might be because oftentimes
if they're trying something they're
being present in some kind of reality
that maybe is even better than what i
would come up with
and so my job is often just to be a
cheerleader and to be
like the person that's just trying to
encourage
spontaneity
um and then you shape it from there um
and so i think that that sort of our our
you know is the same cinematographer
same production designer um as
everything sucks and so there was like
an element of just like
we're back in rural oregon making this
thing with our friends even though we're
on this giant stage and it's she's the
lead of a movie for amazon but it didn't
i didn't want it i didn't want that
pressure
i didn't want any of us to feel any kind
of pressure you know
yeah and i want and that's i'm glad you
ended on that button because i want to
talk about being on this ginormous stage
uh
obviously this is uh
depends so much
on the sort of
geometry of the frame and
how you're picturing this world uh can
you talk a little bit about the set
design of the film and and sort of
realizing that
yeah well adam riemer was our production
he's our production designer a very good
friend
and
i'm so
so so talented um
beyond talented i'm just so lucky to
you know i worked with him on everything
sucks um because he was a portly you
know primarily because he was based in
portland and uh and he had worked on
like shows like grim and things like
that and i just loved his vibe and then
but then we became really really good
friends and then it turns out he he you
know
he is
he is just so exceptional at trying to
figure out how to
a create spaces that
that feel like they accurately reflect
who the characters are and b
untangle the logistical issues with
actually trying to
like make it believable you know because
essentially what we had it was really
complicated we had to find the the
practical location like the actual like
the exterior of the building and all of
that we defined that in reality right
um and not only that our location
manager lou bengal who is like my my
hero he
had to then clear all the apartments uh
all the buildings but then all the all
the people who lived in that apartment
had had to say like oh yeah it's okay if
a movie shoots here for three days
which is like
crazy hard
and once we had those that sort of hero
like practical location we then had to
design the ninth floor of it of each of
those things on a stage and so the
facade of the building the outside of it
like the brick on one side like the
steel on the other had to mimic the
dimensions of the real of the real
location but then the interior of what
they look like like had to we did it
ours like we sort of created it
ourselves like we we created whatever
um like the layout is is is uni is and
isn't what the real building is like
right
and within that layout we had to map out
the vantage point like if you're in
thomas's office for instance you can't
really like see into certain aspects of
the room and so
we were
like because the walls like just the
you're right the geometry was tricky
and
similarly elijah and i had to really map
it all out using um because it's the
movie's primarily set it wasn't like
just we weren't i didn't want to repeat
a shot i wanted every scene to have a
different
just feel unique and different without
it being gimmicky you know
um and so we had to plot all of these
things out perfectly and um
and yeah it was just that was that was
the challenge of the movie was actually
figuring all of that out um
[Music]
um yeah
and and we were talking a little bit
before we started
rolling here and you said it's sort of
been a crazy week watching
the reactions to the film online
has there
how has the response uh to the film
surprised you or
you know confused you or encouraged you
it's been very encouraging um it's uh
you know it
i've been working on this thing since
2016.
and i had this idea for a twist
in 2016.
and now it's finally 20 21
and i get to open up twitter and see
animated gifs of people's jaws dropping
to the floor because they didn't see
this twist coming
and regardless of what you think of the
movie i i think that the twist is
something that people
do not predict
and that to me feels like it just feels
like i can only imagine that it must be
like what a magician feels when they
like step off the stage you know yeah um
and it feels very gratifying and
uh and it really makes me excited that
that this genre
that has gone dormant for so long maybe
has a chance at a second life and maybe
i'll be able to be at the forefront of
of bringing it back in this in this
hopefully socially conscious way
i i certainly i certainly hope so as
well um
well and and to to to that end my final
question here are you at liberty to
discuss anything you are working on next
did i freeze
well i can tell you what i'm doing right
now simultaneously but i've also i i
within the erotic thriller within the
subgenre of erotic thriller there are
other sub genres right you've got you've
got movies like um
like like body heat wild things that are
more like you know sweating on wars
right you have films like ours that is
more like a steamy moral dilemma where
it's like the audience goes okay what
would you do
and then you also have the blank from
hell movies like the nanny from hell in
um hannah rocks the cradle or the
roommate from hell and single white
female and i have an idea for i really
want to do a moral dilemma that's
couched in a blank from hell movie where
the concept is just so sticky um that
you know you can see the poster you can
see the trailer and you're just like yep
that's that's a blank from hell movie
and it's steamy and i wonder what i
would do if i was stuck in that
situation
um but i want to do it on a you know on
a
i want the next one to not be set in two
rooms let's just say that yeah
well i i can't wait to see that film um
i i certainly think you're you're you're
serving an a a market that's been
underserved for far too long thank you
matt i appreciate that and i i really
love the film and i just want to thank
you again for taking the time to hang
out with us and our viewers well thank
you for thank you for helping spread the
word i really really appreciate it
[Music]
you